a big night for ted lasso and a big
night for the small screen hello
everyone and welcome to et live's emmy's
after show i'm denny directo and i'm
cassie delaura we will have some
exciting guests joining us to break
everything down in detail but first
let's take a look at the night's biggest
moments starting with the winningest
shows i'm talking about ted lasso people
ted lasso picked up four statues for its
first season including outstanding
comedy series and outstanding lead actor
for jason sedakis meanwhile the crown
did what everyone expected it swept the
acting categories and snagged the emmy
for outstanding drama winning seven
total emmys tonight and we can't talk
wins without mentioning gene smart's
history making victory after 11 previous
nominations three of which she won in
guest and supporting roles the actress
finally saw emmy glory winning
outstanding lead actress in a comedy
series for her role in hacks and get
this jean joins betty white as the only
two performers to complete an emmy
trifecta winning in the comedy lead
supporting and guest categories for all
different shows we love to see it and
let's not forget rupaul who just went
down in emmy's history books as the most
awarded black artist ever for his work
on rupaul's drag race after picking up
his fourth consecutive victory in the
outstanding competition program category
on sunday
with all of that being said let's dig
into the big wins and what they mean and
helping us to do that tonight is et
online senior producer and our very own
tv expert leanne aguilera co-signed
seriously this girl has seen
everything on tv starting with ted lasso
leanne gotta ask you did you believe
ted would win the big prize i see i'm so
proud of you right there
if you didn't get a little ted leslie
it's in the show it's in the show if i
could give you some biscuits right now
to celebrate heads when i would i am not
shocked at all that this show has
absolutely crushed you know it was
nominated for 20 nominations this year
and it actually beat out glee as the
most nominated freshman comedy in emmy's
history so the fact that they scored
four wins tonight you know you know
what's a lot of goals i can't get past
the fact that it took shit's creek six
seasons before the tv academy said this
is the outstanding comedy of the year
and of course ted lasso first season out
the gate boom they won uh so but it's
kind of nice to see all that emmy's love
for a show that's so beloved but also so
new yes a thousand percent and i know a
lot of people out there have mixed
thoughts on season two but if you have
not watched ted last night with the
mixed thoughts you're talking about
uh it is such a fun show it was so
necessary during this time it's just a
little drop of heaven so definitely
check it out i think it all started with
commercials and then actually fun fact
jason sedakis's ex olivia wilde was the
one who really kind of propelled it to
the success that it is and was like you
need to create something bigger than
just these commercials and look what
it's done and look at all these that are
kind cool again i think i saw my
favorite reaction to ted lasso and jason
winning too was that they're loving
jason's breakup era they're like this is
so hot right now
it is i mean look at him jason went on
to win the best actor in a comedy series
taking the stage to accept the award and
he gave the audience this special moment
when he thanked his mentor lorne
michaels from snl i want to thank lauren
who went to go take a dump now perfect
[Applause]
[Music]
he'll he's going to get home he's going
to watch it he loves watching the emmys
at home
uh full disclosure lauren was in the
press room okay during james not in the
restroom well snow had just picked up
outstanding variety series you know uh
but he did say that jason will be making
a return to snl so maybe just maybe
we'll get another dance moment from
jason like he did and ted lasso leanne
speaking of jason and just his role
leading this whole ship and and just
being ted and totally embodying it were
you surprised at all that he took home
this win or you were like no this is
this is a shoe-in cassie i would be
surprised if he had not won today okay
honestly like if jason said siddiques
had not walked home with the win i think
there honestly would have been riots in
the street because he just was so
perfect in this first season i will say
i am very glad that he dressed up for
the occasion and left that timeline at
home
but considering jason just won the
golden globe the sag award the critics
choice award had he not won this emmy it
would have been a huge missed
opportunity by the way we also did gift
jason a hoodie on the red carpet so
you'll have to check out et online for
that full interview but speaking of that
interview here's a little clip of jason
on the red carpet talking to e.t about
the show
we didn't know that going in i i mean
there was definitely a point of view and
a philosophy of the character and that
sort of sprinkled through the show but
had no idea that that people were going
to be um
so so wonderfully thirsty for it you
know and keep wanting to go back for
refills
the tv academy also showed some love for
his co-stars we got to talk about hannah
waddingham she took home the supporting
actress award toward the beginning of
the night her speech brought a smile to
our faces take a listen i'm so
privileged to work with you i really am
oh my god i'm giving a speech
like you're watching a woman's dream
come true
and she was having the most the best
you could tell she was enjoying every
second and purely that is someone who
was living in the moment and so grateful
to be there i think it really set the
tone for the emmys having her win one of
the first awards of the night it was
just infectious joy just like ted the
show well from comedy to drama let's
start with the winner for outstanding
drama series
the crown
thank you the television academy thank
you netflix and
we're just this is we're gonna have a
party now
i'm lost for words and i'm very very
grateful thank you
[Applause]
leanne now the crown was predicted to
win and it has swept the night
but here's the question what makes the
series stand out this year compared to
previous seasons so that it took home
all these awards oh my gosh cassie i
think it honestly is just because we
entered the era of the one and only lady
diana smith
like she because we finally got to this
time within the crown it really
reinvigorated the show but also the
acting was top-notch like everyone
deserved to win in their categories i
love the fact that they pulled a shit's
creek this year and just swept them off
everything every drama acting category
was someone from the crown but you know
i think all eyes were on lead actress
and the drama of course olivia coleman
took that prize she was up against her
co-star emma corin as princess diana and
she you know emma won the golden globe
were you a little surprised here that
ultimately went to olivia honestly i was
a little bit surprised because i did
think that emma had it in the bag but
i'm so thrilled that it did go to olivia
because this was her last year playing
queen elizabeth ii she has not won an
emmy before if you can believe it so the
fact that she was able to get this and i
love the fact that claire foy who was
our previous queen elizabeth also won an
emmy this year for just i think she had
a five minute scene so she won for uh
outstanding guest actress in a drama but
no pressure for um uh imelda staunton
who's taking over as queen elizabeth in
the next two seasons of the crown also
olivia coleman won an oscar and an emmy
now for playing british royalty so
leanne do i have to give this another
shot yes i didn't make it past episode
five i gotta be honest i did it i fell
asleep
here's what i will say if you want to
get into the crown start off with this
most recent season and that way you can
just drop into this new world and then
if you like the pace of it all you can
go back and re-watch it look at it as
like a mini chapter in history oh there
you go that's a good one that's a good
perspective
well listen some heavy hitters also in
the lead actor category two let's take a
look at tonight's winner the crown will
continue to sweep the night as josh
o'connor took home the award for lead
actor his portrayal of prince charles
has been a critical favorite as well as
the show's acclaim this year leanne did
you see this win coming sure did cass
sure did cass once you watch the season
you will see
john
is amazing and there will be times that
you want to punch him in the face but
it's only because he's acting out
history
and he's such a fun guy and i love how
he also dedicated his speech to emma who
he shared so many scenes with in in that
series this show seems like it's got the
team i think it's got the two royals
cassie i think that this is a show first
you guys we gotta talk about limited
series they ended the whole night with
that category and i think it's because
there were so you it was anybody's right
to win exactly well it went to of course
the queen's gambit um it was such a
competitive category uh but this does
wrap up a big run for the queen's gambit
uh why do you think it's deserving of
the statue i honestly think they said it
properly at the end of the show this
show made chess cool again like it
brought
but i really just think that
seeing her in this role was something
that we had never seen before and it was
at a time where we all were stuck inside
so everyone was just talking about the
show i was a little worried that it's
over popularity was going to take it out
of the running but it was nice to see
that this show actually had what it
takes to take home the gold i was
rooting for one division i'm not gonna
lie
i think a lot of people weren't it would
have been really cool to see marvel be
able to take home the emmy for that but
you know one division did pick up a
couple creative arts enemies but uh i
think it really was between the queen's
gambit and mayor of east town but we did
see that mayor got quite a few wins as
well they sure did more british royalty
right there mayor of east town actually
won three emmys
by the way it was nominated for 16.
that's how good it is it nabbed awards
for including outstanding lead actress
supporting actress and supporting actor
kate winslow one of my favorites
accepted the award her second emmy in
this category and she acknowledged in
her speech how important it is for women
in hollywood to support each other take
a listen i just want to acknowledge my
fellow nominees in this decade that has
to be about women having each other's
backs i support you i salute you
i'm proud of all of you
what can't she do okay and here's
another whippy caterer look at how you
go and i know this is her second emmy
win in this category but i just love
that she's embracing tv she's embracing
streaming and obviously she is embracing
hbo too she's embracing where the good
content is at you guys everyone has been
sleeping on tv i'm telling you it's all
we're consuming oh my god exactly well
we're gonna be consuming some champagne
with you later to thank you for joining
us today liam we appreciate you as well
that's right but we're not done yet
though
you guys can catch more of our
interviews by the way on et online.com
still to come though we love this
journey for them the shit's creep cast
reunites for the emmys moment we didn't
know we needed that and more just more
musty moments after this plus the
night's most memorable looks we've got a
full fashion recap on the other side of
the break we're back in two minutes